foreign
weighs only 6 Kilograms even though
she's 9 years old she lives in Yemen and
is a victim of War
she has malnutrition the doctor said
that she must stay in the hospital for
three months to be treated but we could
not because we do not have the necessary
expenses to buy milk and biscuits
because we have nothing
like hundreds of other yemenis selwa and
her family live in a radish Camp it's
located in the hajja governorate in
Northern Yemen and shelters those who've
been forced from their homes by conflict
but life here is tough
families are crowded inside these tiny
shelters made of sticks and straw water
is hard to get and there's no Sanitation
people are forced to search through
rubbish dumps to find food and anything
that will help them survive
I am looking for plastic cans to sell I
have a child who does not go to school
he and I go to work like this my husband
is disabled at home if we eat in the
morning we will not have dinner and if
we have dinner we will not have lunch we
fled our region and we are here our
condition is very bad and we have
nothing
this woman says it's difficult to give
children here the care they need
so if a child gets sick we do not find
him the required treatment or any other
thing the stores of the organizations
are full of mattresses and water
containers but we can't find containers
to put water in we suffer from both the
sun and the cold living in rags of
tarpaulin as you can see
every family in this Camp is suffering
from extreme poverty they go out
searching for anything they might come
across or for a neighbor who might have
some food to share and other camps the
organization's distribute stuff but here
they give neither food nor soap nor
water containers we have some worn out
blankets that are two years old it's
tragic
camps like this one US Yemen
it's one of the poorest countries in the
world
and the Civil War has made people's
lives worse
eight years ago Jose militias backed by
Iran marched from the north and took the
capital Sana the elected government was
forced into exile
and in Alliance of Arab countries
launched an air bombardment campaign to
restore the ousted government but the
conflict hasn't stopped
it's caused the death of hundreds of
thousands of civilians and forced
Millions to flee their homes the United
Nations describes it as the world's
worst humanitarian crisis it says 2.3
million children under the age of five
don't have enough food and 400 000 of
them are suffering from severe
malnutrition